améliia irange français Orange ouais
très bien
oui Émilie bleu ouais bleu c'est un
cours de de langue sifflée c'estàdire
que nous enseignons la la version
sifflée de l'occiitant ce cours unique
en France est donné une fois toutes les
de semaines au collège les C monts à la
reince apprendre ce langage sifflé
autrefois pratiqué dans le petit village
das à quelques kilomètres d'ici fait
partie des cours d'occitan que reçoivent
ses élèves à tout début de cours nous
allons faire l'appel mais bien sûr cet
appel se fera en langue sifflée
oui k roman c'est
bien je suis en 4e et j'apprends la
langue sil depuis 3 ans depuis que je
suis en 6e petite activit différente ben
ma commenç Matis va devoir choisir de
siffler un mot qui désigne un plat ouais
plat là alors loup puisqu acouat voilà
il y a certaines personnes qui diront
que c'est une langue morte perso moi je
trouve ça cool que les personnes qui ont
appris cette langue le transmettent aux
générations suivante la langue sifflée
en fait c'est éteinte en 1999 avec le le
décès de la dernière siffleuse qui qui
connaissait ce langage de façon native
et nous sommes en train d'essayer de
revitaliser cette pratique depuis les
années 2010 et donc actuellement les la
plupart des siffleurs sont des des des
jeunes qui ont été formés dans dans les
écoles ou au collège de la reunse alors
médiathèque P donc s'appelle gu hein
giath
u du
1 la langue sifflée ce n'est jamais
qu'une une extension de la langue orale
donc lorsqu'on pratique une langue
sifflée on essaie tout simplement de
parler en sifflant alors par exemple si
on veut siffler l'occitant le français
ou l'anglais site ben ça va donner
quelque chose qui ressemble à à la
version orale on ne sait pas s'il a été
inventé sur place ou s'il a été apporté
c'est une influence extérieure et on ne
sait pas non plus depuis quand on le
pratique tout ce qu'on sait c'est que à
la fin des années 50 les plus vieux
siffleurs ont pu on peut dire aux
enquêteurs qui qui sont venus étudier le
langage sifflé que leurs grands-parents
quand ils étaient enfants eux-mêmes
pratiquaiit déjà ce ce langage c'est un
béarnet qui en 2006 a souhaité refaire
apparaître la langue sifflée
il est allé se former au Canaris sur
l'île de la Goméra où des habitants
communiquent encore ainsi en espagnol
entre deux
vallées on ne siffle pas
uniquement on siffle dans d'autres
régions du monde il y a plusieurs
langues qui disposent d'une version
sifflée plusieurs dizaines de de
langues la langue clé était utilisée
surtout pour des pour des besoins
utilitaires de bon sifleurs auraiit pu
communiquer de de part et d'autre de la
de la
vallée oh
Bernard tu vas passer à
l'épicerie
tu vas m'acheter une boîte de
sardines et une baguette de pain donc
voilà c'est une phrase un peu plus un
peu plus longue et qui qui aurait pu
être sifflée sans problème et être
comprise sans
problème